[Music]
Catherine this turkey tastes half as
good as it looks I think we're all in
for a very big treat save the neck for
me Clark okay
I sure can't happen though if I'm
cooking anyway don't always go according
to plan but even if it's not
picture-perfect studies show that having
family traditions helps make the holiday
season brighter we have New York Times
bestselling author Gretchen get over
what happened that turkey I know but
what is it though tony was it burnt and
you open it up very dry but when he says
it was overcooked
good I was confused too did stay with me
yes we have New York Times bestselling
author Gretchen Rubin to talk about how
to hold on to this very season all year
long Gretchen thank you for being here
Gretchen
so things can't go poorly yeah yeah when
you have a plan but you say it's
important to keep those traditions
anyway with what's the benefit
absolutely research shows that
traditions really do bind families
together they allow them to spend more
time together they enjoy it more they
find it more interesting it allows us to
mark the passage of time we can show
people like you're one of us now cuz
you're gonna join in this tradition
whether it's something like doing a
giant puzzle or having a special meal it
promotes connection doesn't it really
does it's unique to your group it makes
you feel like this is what makes us us
and sometimes the things that go wrong
make the best memories you blow up the
chicken that's okay so it's relatively
easy to participate in a long-standing
tradition but you know there are people
that were put maybe hosting for the
first time try you becoming the father
the the leading the the Christmas mom
doing the same how do you start that
tradition how do you go from like we've
never knew tradition sounds like an
oxymoron but you can really start them
and you know sometimes it's fun to do it
with minor things the big holidays like
what can swell like the first day of
spring or a groundhog day or this year
you know we have leap day you have a
family tradition what are you gonna do
on leap day be fun to get that going
figure out what are we gonna do and then
we can do it for now on or there a way
to celebrate or create and celebrate
family traditions all year long right
well I think you can look at any of
these opportunities where you think well
what's kind of an open space on our
calendar and how do we make it easy like
I like to use food dye like dry
something green dye something pink to
make it feel like it's special and you
take a photograph this is the way we do
it is special to our family it doesn't
have to be a huge big deal like the
major holidays so many people feel I
think Gretchen pressure to be perfect on
the holidays and to that you say what
don't let the perfect be the enemy of
the good and so now you don't want to be
the person who wants everything to be so
perfect that you drive everyone crazy
and so if you are one of those people to
try to let go of that fantasy of
perfection especially sometimes like if
somebody's not there like they didn't
make the trip or maybe they're gone and
so it doesn't feel like it's the right
turn it you know if things aren't quite
right sometimes you might have to
reinvent a holiday to make a new a new
shape if things are changing their life
pictures people are taking the extra
sconces right but it sounds like you
were saying also print it put in an
album make it exist in three dimensions
right yeah so research shows that
looking at photographs reminding
ourselves of happy times in the past is
one of the best time ways to make
ourselves happy now I believe that yes
so strongly yeah if you know what
happens when you're taking pictures they
seem annoying yeah one more photo wait
we didn't get that let's try it again
people are moaning and groaning and
groaning and I was is a bitching and
complaining and complaining but then you
get that picture and you look at it
later and it's actually fun well and the
great thing is now because if most
people do it with digital albums yeah
it's just easy to make three as it is to
make one so then you can give that and
nothing makes us happier than giving
sort of a precious gift and those
photographs like they're irreplaceable
if you're the one who took the holiday
pictures that's a wonderful gift what's
your advice for using this time to our
advantage and not letting it slip away
because it goes so quickly
you know you put it up and then before
you know you're taking it all down so
well there's a lot of things you can
kind of clear clutter as you go one is
there decorations that you never
actually take out go ahead and give them
away if you notice that you need
something like twinkle lights or candles
well go ahead and buy them now for the
holiday sale sales are on sale they're
on sale get them for next year it's very
discouraging when you see those holiday
decorations up for months I mean here in
New York City like how late do we see
trees on the sidewalk maybe give
yourself a day like
near XIV is the date we're going to take
down our holiday decorations it's Eve
you're gonna start a controversy weekend
yeah but pick a date we disagree with
New Year's Eve okay take it back like
just a date just the way you don't give
your date when you put them up
Ozzie because that can sort of drag on
and then also when you're putting things
away look for opportunities to give
things away that you're not I like that
all right Gretchen move been always good
to see you thank you have a plan
you